the fastest way to achieve any goal
overcome any obstacle is to model
success find someone who's already
accomplished what you're trying to do
and put their strategies to work for you
success leaves clues you just have to
follow them otherwise you're going to
end up pounding your head going in the
wrong direction spending dollars time
energy effort going in a path that
doesn't serve you when I had my first
business it was a software company and
it seemed to take forever to get
anything that to go we put so much time
and effort and work into our ideas and
nothing seemed to happen it took forever
to get customers to say yes to us and
for any momentum to really build and
four months I took out three hundred
dollars a month from the business and
that just wasn't enough you know it's
not enough it's not a honey survival for
that I remember my friends would want to
go out and hang out after work invite me
to birthday parties and I had to once a
month sit in front of my computer pull
up my calendar take a deep breath and
then figure out which one event I was
going to go to and which of all the
other ones that was going to reject
because it can only afford to do one
thing per month and it was too
embarrassed to tell my friends who were
making 80,000 a year as investment
bankers that I can't come out and have
drinks or dinner with you because I
can't afford the 20 bucks to do it you
know also to be living the dream I'm
supposed to be living the
entrepreneurial life and that got to me
you know like you can only do that for
so long before you you've burst and
there came a point where I had to say
this isn't working the way things are
going now it's not working I need to
either quit and move on to something
else or need to find another way to
stand because as it works this is not
going to happen for me I'm going to
light bulb went off and I told myself
you know what I'm not the first guy to
try to sell software before and our
research companies like Microsoft and
how they got started and figured if they
can make it work maybe there's some
lessons and their success that I can
learn from
and so I copied guys like Bill Gates and
I don't care how Bill Gates makes extra
million dollars now but how do you go
from zero to one that was interesting
how do you go from that idea to making
his first million dollars that's what I
wanted to do and he didn't do
partnerships you found people who
already were selling to his target
market and he found a way to partner up
with them so I started doing that and
within a couple weeks I had landed a
deal with a company in the UK who wanted
to represent us and they agreed to pay
thirteen thousand dollars up front for
the right to represent us and I remember
looking at the agreement the signed
contract from them where they would
agree to pay us 13 thousand dollars and
it was just a look of shock you know the
swallow hard and smiling from ear to ear
unbelievable that this has just happened
i was making 300 bucks a month and now
we had thirteen thousand dollars coming
in but i also now had a path of how we
can get that again and again and again
in a new process that i could plot in my
business and suddenly we had momentum
and it was frustrating as well as
exciting because I should have figured
this out a long time ago why did I have
to hit rock bottom to figure that out
and so for you and your business I hope
you don't have to hit rock bottom before
you figure out that there's a faster
path to success find someone who's
already accomplished what you're trying
to do and put their strategies to work
for you mon success is going to be the
fastest way that you can achieve any
goal or overcome any obstacle in front
of you I hope you apply it to your
business good luck